The so-called Knapsack Problem is
another famous thought exercise in
computer science.
Here we have a theoretical knapsack
with a limited weight capacity, and
more items that can possibly fit in it.
Each item has a weight and a value.
The question here is, how can I optimize
the total value of items in my knapsack,
given the weight constraint?
We'll focus on the 0-1 knapsack problem,
where you only have
one of each object and you must
either take or leave a whole object.
In some other variants,
you can take a fraction of an object.
When I heard about this problem,
my first thought was,
just put the objects with
the highest values in first.
but what if putting the two elements
with the highest values hit the weight
limit, but putting all the other
elements in together would actually fit
and have a higher value?
There aren't a lot of actual
knapsacks in computer science, but
this problem describes an optimization
issue that crops up often.
Before devising the best solution,
particularly if you're stuck, it can be
helpful to think of the solution
that's slow but straightforward.
Here we could try every
combination of objects and
just pick the one that's best,
also called the brute force solution.
The runtime of the solution is on
the order of 2 raised to the n,
where n is the number of objects.
There are actually 2 to
the n possible combinations.
There's a precise mathematical
reason for this, but
you could also think of one
combination as a string of length n,
where each spot has a 1 if it's in
the knapsack or a 0 if it's left out.
That means this is an exponential time
algorithm, since the n is an exponent.
We would prefer
a polynomial time algorithm
where the n is multiplied by something
else or has a constant number for
an exponent, which is going to be
much faster for large numbers.